[Musik]
alex
alexa kaffee so alexa die zdf mediathek
guten namen bei den damen und herren
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
[Musik]
[Applaus]
smart home smart people scheiße was
machst du denn hier
alexa lichter der crazy althippie hat
sich ein beknackte smarthome
eingerichtet ich dachte du wolltest nie
spießer werden
das geht dich das und überhaupt das
ganze hier das ist ein bruch ja das ist
naja digitaler ein wo ich keine ahnung
gibt das überhaupt scheiß drauf egal
raus ich glaub es hackt mit meinem
smarthome habe ich alles unter kontrolle
apropos es hakt deine digitale heute ist
natürlich miserabel gesichert war
absolut easy sich da rein zu hacken
verstehst du es hakt ich liebe mein
smart um das machen wir nicht auch noch
mal ich bin super gs alles sprach und
app gesteuerter hier drin hier bin ich
gott meine liebreizenden assistentin
alexa fernseher aus nein
dein haus ist gott sieht alles alles
einen tisch ist das wohnzimmer wärmer
und der wein keltern
[Musik]
also ich heute immer noch zu guck mal
der verein kühlschrank hat 9,5 grad ja
ganz konstant es ist total hier
verbunden mit amazon alex abbestellen
auch mal eine kiste blieb alexa meine
eigene private angestellte mann alex
arbeitet nicht für mich sondern für
immer sinn
du bist hier die ware die wissen die
letzte kiste hast du vor drei tagen
bestellt und sagen sich achten
guck mal der alexander held gern mal ein
david ihm doch direkt auch gleich mal
kopfschmerztabletten und potenzpillen ja
wie bisher wie alte bist und man weiß ja
alkohol verengt die gefäße deine mutter
verengt die gefäße die hersteller sorgen
sich um meine sicherheit da ist der
passwortschutz schon mit drin
überhaupt wie wirst du hier ein gekommen
war ganz leicht toto weil du idiot wie
die meisten idioten noch nicht mal das
vom hersteller voreingestellte passwort
geändert hat warum dann also doch viel
besser im passwort ausdenken als ich
gott das ist der zentrale punkt eines
netzwerks alle geräte laufen am hut er
zusammen wenn ich da drin bin bin ich in
jedem gerät
ich kann die kamera an deinem smart tvs
aktivieren oder dir an deinem blätter
jeden tag sechs stunden videos von dir
zu hause auf den server irgendwelcher
konzerne
ich könnte da eine sitcom rausschneiden
[Musik]
rupprecht tag und überall kameras die
sowieso nie ein einbrecher zu sehen
kriegen ja im zweifelsfall heckt der
einbrecher ein handy und guckt mit
deinen kameras nach ob du gerade zu
hause bist du verschenkt sein
privatleben nur wurde zuvor bis den
lichtschalter selbst zu bedienen
aber das ist ja auch zu weit weg ein
staubsauger roboter übrigens nicht so
harmlos wie er aussieht denn tracks wie
groß seine wohnung ist die grundriss und
das meer dann alles dem hersteller und
der sitzt wahrscheinlich in china
ja gut aber die alternative die wir ja
ganz genau selber staubsaugen
streaming ist smart hoch zwei super
torwart
nein die großen streamingdienste ja die
sind die schlimmsten stalker von allen
die speichern was du guckst wie lange ob
bei einer sexszene noch einmal zurück
spur
die haben ein persönlichkeitsprofil ob
du schwul bist oder etoro links oder
rechts manisch oder depressiv es ist der
blanke sie wissen alles über dich
unschuldige privatsphäre geschändet auf
den müll geworfen was die wissen und ein
stuhl nein das nicht
noch nicht smart home ist für dummies
wasser etwa drei folgenden game of
thrones beim kacken gekommen ich musste
mich ablenken
ich finde das furchtbar ich wollte ein
smartes haus und kannst mich ausspähte
für voll
für wirklich alle dir was verkaufen
wollen einbrecher oder deine kranken
oder hausratsversicherung und natürlich
durch sich übrigens über die hälfte der
deutschen ja die würden nicht in ein
smart oben einziehen weil weil sie die
ganze scheiße nicht brauchen und ihre
daten nicht verschenken wollen
es heißt ja vielleicht gut und schön
die story gibt keine widerworte die für
jeden wunsch
wenn wir jetzt noch uhr hätte damit das
perfekte freundin aber was du machst
dich mach schluss
ich versteh ich mache ich bloß nicht ich
will dass der ganze kam hier
verschwindet ich will wieder ein dummes
hausrechts nur ein dummes haus ist ein
gutes aus wasserkraft
mein freund hat letzte mal bei mir
gesagt ich bin so stolz auf dich jetzt
ändern wir noch deine mutter passwort
damit unseriöse typen wie ich keinen
zutritt mehr haben ja du ich hab richtig
gut ist besorgt da warte warte warte ich
laut aussprechen stelle hier
pantomimisch dar
ein ort was was soll das sein ist das
eine odere was nein nein nein ist kein
gutes passwort erster wäre ein zwei drei
vier fünf
das versteht doch keine sau internet
internet 20 28 was für ein idiot am
besten hier abonniert jetzt erstmal den
kanal er und schaut euch das nächste
video an ihm vorbei dazu gelegenheit
also was